[Music]
in unique side-effects new unique New
York unique New York unique New York
I don't believe you Nikko Uniqlo give me
clothing submitted by JK say hey to K
hey okay
oh hey k that was good and then is
blaming prescription painkillers for
turning him gay
oh [ __ ] Robinson made sin gamma to me
[ __ ]
so I took some vicodin and I started
sucking some dick was it your own dick
nah just nap that happens to me five I
found the truth I could see I won't
judge it could be the other way around
is like he got caught sucking dick is
for vicodin cuz he was like jonesing for
some vicodin oh it's a vicodin - me me
gay to afford it oh I thought you meant
like vicodin that you're hallucinating a
little bit and he was doing karaoke haha
I think that this person grew up in a
very conservative household and then
when they found out he was gay he made
up that [ __ ] have you guys never
talked to a dude with like a five
o'clock shadow or a mustache and then
imagine kissing them someone is down a
kiss that and I would see that I'm like
with a with a man and the thing that
you're thinking about a man like can I
kiss this guy already had that thought
would Joe only circumstance I would kiss
just for a scene those are funny scene
on the okay I'll kiss you for a funny
scene but I'm not gonna kiss you on the
right they're not gonna kiss you on the
bed like I guess I guess I kind of
understand because every time I see a
cop with neither your [ __ ] best
friends of course you understand because
it's like I have the same thought like
every time I see a cop with a gun out
I'm like what if I just grabbed it and
ran yup
it's a prank bro yeah like that you know
it's that feeling in that thought right
yeah my mind doesn't go there time I
thought about and there's nothing wrong
with thinking that I'm just I just wish
we had these conversations in private
before everyone in this room knows about
like we're just like you're like hey Ben
can you [ __ ] put the toilet seat down
oh by the way when I was imagining
kissing this other dude why would I ever
come up talking to a bunch of other [ __ ]
like we're sure legit the only time I've
ever thought I had to kiss a guy is for
acting like can I do it yeah like if it
was a film about me being in like a
heterosexual relationship and I to [ __ ]
a guy on-screen homosexual oh I'm sorry
homosexual you know it's a lie I don't
know if I'd be able to do that just cuz
I can't get in that mind stick I
wouldn't even be able to get in the mind
seat to watch the movie of you [ __ ]
anyone I could I would watch it to
support David thank you it might be his
next sundance film never you [ __ ] a
girl for maybe women yeah I'm gonna make
FL much it's about me [ __ ] and I'm
only gonna fight you a whole theater
rule it's gonna be locked and chained up
and then Bart's gonna be like you [ __ ]
up cuz I already know about your goddamn
plant so if you asked me to [ __ ] go
and it's party of one I'm gonna be like
nah man he's also a crop crop rate with
this planet yeah that's called a coronal
David ya know it's gonna be artsy
alright so this guy here French movie
famous Scott he's 23 years old from the
UK okay and so he broke his foot and a
go-karting accident caused him to be gay
huh he's gay after that yeah initially
he started taking codeine but then he
had some negative side effects so then
he ended up having to take preggers
baleen all those terms
aka lyrica for us in the u.s. lyric
America dope ass name get hella right
how the rap take you just because it's
called lyrica yeah
start [ __ ] freestyling on the mic
with he's so pissed at that [ __ ] box
no think now I'm wearing pink cuz I'm
[ __ ] dead like a rock every [ __ ]
day dicks in my brain dicks in my brain
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man
painkillers turned me gay looks like the
kid from Sandlot Oh like the the fact is
you played the fat kid in all the movies
it the lyric guy she can't stop saying
it liquor ah you [ __ ] it up era he
feels like he was in a relationship for
six months with also he didn't know how
to break up with a girl oh he looks like
he's like he's harvesting something evil
behind her why does he look like a Sith
Lord and [ __ ] he does yeah here's
another photo of them together so they
were dating for six months and he's
saying that once he started taking
lyrica that they drinking vanilla syrup
that looks like just bottles of syrup
from Starbucks you know I don't want to
I think it's Zima I think it's probably
still exist somewhere I should remember
from that TV yeah there's some sort of
trash that's don't drink that [ __ ] it
does look like that looks just like it
yeah it's probably Zima how do you know
they have gross beer in the UK they
could probably be drinking Zima one
thing is that she looked like Zima
it's just so sad that one he can't lie
like that's just sad he's trying to
break up with this girl no so let me
tell you so then he ends up taking his
painkillers and then slowly he stopped
seeing his girlfriend attractive or any
other woman for that matter so he was
like what the hell this is weird I'm not
even interested in girls anymore so and
he stopped taking the pain meds he
started liking guys and he stopped like
you know relaxed his conditioning his
societal conditioning and so his true
came out so when he went when he was on
painkillers he was gay when he's off
painkillers he's straight yes but then
he felt happy about his sexuality and
gave him a liberating feeling when he
was on the painkiller so he went back to
pay relaxed his condition being that
like his wold I think that he's gay and
addicted to [ __ ] painkillers he
sounds like he had never been interested
in men but when he was younger he was a
little bit curious for a couple weeks
he was already gay but then now that
he's started taking those pain meds like
he did relaxed him like sick cuz
painkillers are muscle relaxers so all
this like built-up tension of having to
need to be a certain way and it just all
got relaxed he's like yeah go [ __ ] I
like that he's happy he's finally don't
blame the painkillers just say man up
big game thank the painkillers for
releasing you he doesn't know himself
yeah he is blaming the painkillers cuz
he's saying if I had known beforehand
that this drug would turn me gay I
wouldn't have taken it nothing wrong
with me gay about it exactly he it
released his inner like who he really is
it like allowed him to be who he is
relaxed I never knew playing the flute
would make me gay cuz I just like suckin
dick that's music the same [ __ ] it's
like it doesn't make sense you've been
gay fool but what is he asking for is he
ask you for a lyric or to have like a
side effect warning above yeah no he
just wants a spotlight
yeah side effects they're gonna thirst
for come like what's gonna happen
currently he's he's talking to this guy
on plentyoffish the app and in a couple
weeks he's gonna go up to see him that
he's in London that it's what he quote
it's what I'm craving right bar you
should hate you pillars and see if your
inhibitions drop I've taken about ton of
painkillers and I still jacked off two
regular girls oh I think the hot girls
is regular
look as my categories once there's
regular girls and there's girls with
dicks so I didn't check off the dose
[Music]
good luck to you you could you couldn't
be like no I still find you attractive
or I wanted to have sex Gio it's like
there's green were David regular girls
and then there's no no when I jacked off
with vicodin
I didn't even that's hard to do was the
oxycontin I don't remember what I gave
me yeah and then jacked off yeah my
roommate gave it to me hey man you do
your extreme jerk or did you like the
type of person who gets the flu and
still has to just whack it off it helps
you sleep yeah whatever I can't sleep I
just masturbate got a fever and a boner
oh yeah Darrel flu is the mother [ __ ]
[ __ ] sometimes you're sick and you have
a boner in that wild [ __ ] is it have a
thriving bars you gotta get rid of them
if I have a fever
cuz I can't do it it just doesn't even
go up because I'm like a throbbing [ __ ]
about your date with the [ __ ]
cucumber out of your [ __ ] pocket
pickle Rick Oh masturbation helps
relieve headaches to them no yeah it
does look it up google it not for me
because you have to like [ __ ]
straining you check off too and you
gotta get I gotta get a really fast so
let it get to your body more going back
to the story though I don't think
anything can make you gay by yourself
that's a lie nothing could make you
turns you gay yeah it's like you just
you just been gay that's what I like
what Nikki says like the Lord isn't her
is inhibition
yeah that's a cool thing already
admitted that he was curious when he was
younger yep yeah I'm glad he uncovered
himself
we should think that painkiller we have
a lot of gay fans come on there was just
as many gay people back then but now
people can be more open yeah totally
that's awesome well look at like the
ancient Greek culture they embraced it
like that would there's no gay
pedophiles yeah they also embraced
pedophilia yeah yeah but there's a lot
of pedophiles - that are still around we
just don't accept that you know I don't
accept it ever same amount of the ratio
of people that are not out in the open
there's no victims yet another victim
yeah we're not even trying to tie that
thing you should at least should accept
it at all yeah no at all I was just
saying that in ancient Greek culture you
saw all of it and I don't think
anything's changed other than our
success societal acceptance I never
understood straight guys that were like
against gays gay guys cuz I was always
like yes more gays please because like
why ladies go exactly no chances if all
the like good-looking guys got like gay
and then oh my god gay and then they're
all like gay together then it's like the
girls standards they go low and then
they're go okay now you know I'll get
with that jealous King was gay the high
school quarterback was gay the all
started basketball player then it's just
like cool in the hottest girls will
start knocking them down and they'll
finally get to like me when I'm like
number like hundred twenty or something
dude in high school I used to just go
guys into it's I do it please gay right
yeah dudes been looking at you yeah I
call all my straight friends gay
yeah just they're putting their hands
together for yeah you like it
[Laughter]
[Music]